we're going to take you now to Rome
because as you recognize that as
President Vladimir zielinski he's just
arrived in Rome in the last couple of
hours
for talks
um with Italian officials and it has
been confirmed with Pope Francis it said
the Vatican has launched a behind the
scenes initiative to try to end the war
launched last year by Russia now those
comments came from Pope Francis at the
end of April
saying that the Vatican was involved in
a behind the scenes peace Mission no
details were given in Russia and Ukraine
haven't confirmed such an initiative but
Mr zielinski arrived at a military
Airfield this morning
he was met by the foreign minister and
he tweeted before he um arrived saying
that today in Rhone I'm meeting with
president of Italy Sergio matarella
prime minister of Italy Giorgio Maloney
and the pope an important visit for
approaching victory of Ukraine so that's
what Vladimir zielinski said he tweeted
ahead of his meeting there or his trip
there meeting with Mr mozarello at the
presidential Palace it's the first
official appointment of what is expected
to be a visit of several hours in the
capital
the exact schedule for Mr zielinski
hasn't been publicly announced obviously
because of security concerns and the
Vatican as I was saying earlier only
confirmed that he was going to meet the
pope shortly before he actually arrived
in Rome
now Italian Italian State TV have been
reporting on the protective measures
obviously that have had to be put in
place for Mr zielinski's visit that
includes a no-fly zone for Rome Skies
armed police strategically placed on
high buildings now in terms of when he
met these people they've meeting today
before he met Ms Maloney in Kiev shortly
before the anniversary of Russia's
full-scale Invasion that was February
last year
Pope Francis he last met in 2020 and
obviously as I was saying Pope Francis
eager for peace and makes frequent pleas
on behalf of Ukraine's what he calls
martyred people people and as I was
saying the Pope told reporters at the
end of April that the Vatican was
involved in a behind-the-scenes peace
Mission gave no details about it neither
Russia or Ukraine confirming such an
initiative so President Vladimir
zelensky has just arrived in Rome for
talks with Italian officials and later
he is going to meet Pope Francis